the main point of what i was bringing up
for this one is uh
is this the whole you know joe biden
thing okay because it's not oh gosh yeah
yeah it's not just uh like it was a new
york times op-ed
saying you know what we're gonna own it
we believe tara reid
whatever we're voting biden anyway i'm
you know you know the point i'm bringing
up is emma i respect it
you and i don't respect the lies and the
double standards where they're like well
joe biden is innocent and we don't think
now i just come on say it man you never
cared it was all just about getting
power that's what you want to do right
yep yeah man so here's what's freaky
about the whole thing for me
to actually come out and admit straight
up you're like
you know we said we cared about this
stuff
we just wanted to win so we're gonna
vote for biden i'm gonna own it
these people don't care about policy
they don't care about principle they
have no plan and they have no argument
yeah
now they're going to get political power
we don't care we hate trump
anything to get rid of trump no it's not
period it's not that's some of their
arguments
but i'm talking about these people just
they just want to win like they just
want the keys
like give me the keys to the castle man
i want to go up and tower and hang out
with the millionaires man the ones who
are giving kanye the secrets i want
secrets
so they'll say whatever it takes yeah
and then once they get in someone hands
them like a stack of folders and they're
like
which economic plan do we do and they're
like
i don't know man i just live here i have
no idea
any of this stuff works i mean i only
just got the keys
it's that's not dead it's like it's like
walking into like you know this like
you're
in a factory right you walk in
everything's going haywire
and you like there's a dude in an office
wearing a suit and you run in and you're
like what do we do it's like
i don't know man i i never did anything
here i just sit here to look like i'm in
charge
i mean they just wanted me actually it
reminds me of family guy
you see the episode where they put him
in charge of the cigarette company no
because he's just a [ __ ] and that gets
him out of the way so they make him ceo
and like let him do whatever something
like that
that's what it is this makes you think
of adam west though oh he's amazing
adam was great yeah but he's the best
he's just he's a clueless mayor though
right
yeah or his marriage he's not clueless
okay crazy
yeah something i'm sorry man mayor west
uh rest in peace uh yeah would be a much
better leader than what we're getting
right now favorite family guy here
because no no hold on because i gotta
agree the
mayor west of coag playing by adam west
yeah actually cared
that's true and he was convinced of bad
policies there was that one episode
where he they changed the drinking age
to 50 and then
you know to 15. yeah and because brian
is 50 in dog years 56
he was able to buy alcohol for everybody
oh that's funny so then peter and then
reason using him to get drunk
but then they they decide to get the law
changed they go to adam west's house
and he's with you know peter's
sister-in-law or whatever
who's drinking wine and they're like
wait a minute she's not 50 you can't
give her you know alcohol and he's like
oh yeah you're right okay we'll change
the law back
wow like you actually said hey this
doesn't work because you did this and he
goes i didn't realize that let me fix it
that is way more than you get from from
a ton of these politicians
who are willing to say whatever they
want to say just to get power i mean
look look at what joe biden's done with
his life
look at look at the weird scandals the
the cronyism
he's lied for a long time oh that video
that went viral yeah what would like you
just kind of know how long yeah
i watched it basically what it is is him
telling
i i guess it's a room full of reporters
like i graduated
top of my class i i i have three phds
from and i was a lawyer and all these
other things it's like
and then they're finding out he was like
all of it bottom ten percent
yeah yeah he graduated with just one
degree and he made it all up
and he said i'm sorry my memory failed
me and that was a long time ago dude if
your memory is failing you when you're
in your 40s and now you're
78 and you want to be president man i
don't know where your memory is going at
this point
but he couldn't even remember a name so
think about the kind of person he is
true
he is he is a swamp monster
yeah donald trump is a different kind of
monster donald trump is an american
culture monster
okay but americans like american culture
stuff that's true so you can argue for
for good or for bad
i'm not i'm not i'm not here to defend
trump you know i hate bringing him up a
reference to biden
but joe biden is the swamp he embodies
it he brings his kid to foreign
countries gets him jobs
flies him on a plane to china doing his
big you know this big deal
his buddy his his son's buddies are
getting these kickbacks you get all the
media lining this stuff up in 2014
joe biden soft corruption all this other
stuff and then what happens oh now he's
president
well i'm not gonna leave malone he he's
a wannabe president
oh yeah sorry sorry now he's running for
president thank you now he's running
no joe biden is not president no he's
running for president wasn't gonna let
that one go by
no that was a that was a i misspoke um i
misspoke i apologize
uh i hope this doesn't reflect poor me
only poorly on me and i will still
have your vote come november no he's
he's the the swamp monster that
is the prop for all the the monsters
that are already embedded that want
the puppet to do what they want them to
do well that's what that's the vibe i
get anyway
obviously i don't know any truth in that
i wonder if
trump really is draining the swamp in
that capacity or if the swamp is just
draining like what i mean is is trump a
symptom of the draining swamp
like the swamp wasn't strong enough to
keep him out hmm
you know you know how i've described it
before he just like runs and jumps into
the swamp and just
all the water gets splashed out and now
the fish are just flapping
this you know you know what i don't
understand about the progressives so the
way to describe described it before is
you have this big ivory tower okay
and you have people like biden and
pelosi there's the keys to the castle
democrats
they just want to let be let in they
want to do anything for you they don't
care
just let them in the castle give them
the money they want to kick back and not
do any real work that's what happens i
mean look look at nancy pelosi i have
all this ice cream i couldn't live with
that it's like dude your district is
full of human waste
there's a lot you could be doing right
now but you know what fine whatever it's
your retirement i get it
so here's what happens bernie sanders
starts marching up with you know a torch
and a bunch of people behind him and he
bangs on the door
let us in the people are angry and want
to change
and then they look down and they go go
away bernie and start throwing stuff at
him he's like
and then the other side they have a bull
with this crazy orange hair
and they just let him go and he runs
full speed and smashes through the door
and starts going like
i'm like stomping around and smashing
windows and all of the elites the
republicans and democrats are screeching
and running around what do we do what do
we do
and they can't reason with the bull the
bull's just like i'm a bull
he just runs up the stairs and so
the point i'm making is donald trump
clearly is not a part of this crony
structure yeah you can argue there's a
ton of things wrong with trump for sure
that's true but i wonder if i'd be right
i wonder why the progressives haven't
haven't just
at this point been like you know what
sit back and let the ball run its course
trump was a democrat wasn't he oh yeah
for a while he
went back and forth yeah he goes back
and forth but it doesn't matter but a
lot of his policies are moderate
and that's not coming my from me that's
vox.com's matthew glacey i believe it
was matthew galacias left-wing website
said trump ran as a moderate
you can call him far right all you want
but that media smear doesn't work that's
like the establishment trying to knock
him down
okay there's a lot of things wrong with
the man in terms of you know character
and statute you know the way he should
be behaving as president things like
that you can have a conversation about
that
but what i don't get is the progressives
should have just been like we'll just
wait this one out
you know what i mean like after the bull
is done and tired and then leaves the
building and just
goes off to to graze in the pasture then
bernie and your people can you know
knock on like there's no door left they
can walk right in yeah the door's been
knocked down so so i think
what would really happen is after the
ball leaves the people who brought the
bull will then stand next to the people
who brought bernie
and there'd be a conversation and it
might not be bernie but
like the establishment is is on its last
leg
the only reason the media entertained
the biden stuff is because it was put
out by the progressives
and they knew they were in trouble with
the new york times i'd be willing to bet
when they ran that defense piece for
biden they started getting tons of
emails from people being like
what are you doing why are you defending
this man because a lot of the a lot of
people who read at times probably
burning supporters
democrats were split so the new york
times was probably scared their bottom
line was getting hit
flip-flopped and called for an
investigation then all of a sudden the
dominoes started falling down and the
narrative broke
and they're forced to acknowledge it
this is the end of the establishment
trump destroyed the republican
establishment bernie wasn't strong
enough to stop the democrat
establishment
but they're they're falling apart
regardless because bernie's supporters
and the progressives
are are ruthless they're really ruthless
men
they're like you know cancel culture all
the way you know but but to bring it
back to the main point
man isn't it refreshing that they're
being honest about
yeah why what what they want to do
absolutely yeah
it's a rare treat it is nice the media
is being honest
oh well it's the it's the people it's
the columnist you know what i mean
true it's it's like name and natural
like name name a a huma a man-made
disaster
and you can predict what the
spokesperson's gonna say
like look at the project veritas story
we covered you know exactly what they're
gonna do well we're we completely deny
any wrongdoing we are totally confused
by this and then like
when you actually see behind the scenes
they're lying your face
i just wish you know man why can't we
have honesty
like it's not even about honesty it's
about balance yin yang man
yeah we only ever get lies yeah it's
annoying
yeah and that's why trump wins that's i
think well it's one of the reasons
guy gets up on stage and he just says
whatever he wants it's refreshing
people are probably lagging that guy's
telling it like it is i like that they
said the same thing about
you know w like he talks like a normal
guy he just says it you know but trump
that dude really just does say it
like my favorite thing ever with with
trump just blurting stuff out is when he
was like
he's being interviewed in front of the
helicopter or whatever in the rose
garden or something
and they're like uh what's going on with
his saudi arabia deal and he goes oh
it's really really great they're gonna
pay us a whole lot of money
they pay really really well it's gonna
be fantastic great for the economy and
all of the anti-war leftists just like
their jaws hit the floor like he just
blurted it out
something the president's not supposed
to admit we sell weapons for cash to
bolster our economy
and then the other funny thing was when
trump said that he was going to be
sending or
we might send troops to saudi arabia
someone in the administration gave a
comment saying saudi arabia pays cash
oh my goodness we're just we're just
getting the truth on this one i can i
can appreciate that
not that i agree with it so yeah
i don't know what to expect man i just
i'm just sick of the lies
and so i'll tell you what i don't expect
the truth from mainstream media
so that's you know you might be wrong
because i'm looking
at a letter to the editor from martin
tolchin who was
a former member of the washington the
times i think the washington times
bureau and a founder of politico
and he's talking about throwing all
democratic values under the bus for joe
biden and i was like
that's refreshing can we get a little
bit more of that i saw i saw that and
apparently someone uh was it molly
hemingway is that her name
possibly from the federalist yeah she i
think she tweeted about it and then
someone got really mad because this this
what's his name tolchin yeah martin
tolchin
is listed as a founder of politico yep
and
wrote this thing what was he basically
saying like forget all our values just
vote biden anyway let me
see what he said he said i totally
disagree with this editorial
i don't want an investigation i want a
coronation of joe biden
would he make a good president unlikely
would he make it good
would he make a great president no would
he make a better president than the
present
present occupant absolutely i don't want
justice whatever that may be i want to
win
the removal of donald trump from office
that's it that's what i was saying
that's all they want just want to beat
trump yeah yeah well they want the keys
to the castle man yeah
you know you know that meme of uh who's
that what's that guy's name
andre i don't know let me in he's
banging him yeah you know that oh yeah
yeah i don't know what
show that's he's hilarious and he's on
the fence
that's what the democrats are saying
right now yeah basically but you know
because
here's what i'll say about trump they're
not arguing anything about him
just saying he's bad doesn't tell me
anything yeah
and you know that's what i get really i
get really frustrated by these pundits
on twitter
when they're like calling uh you know
kaylee mckenney i think is her name
they're like what a ridiculous press
conference she was so dumb she didn't
even say anything and i'm like hold on
bro
you addressed nothing she said you have
told me nothing
if you want to criticize the president
tell me what it is you're criticizing
and tell me what you want to say about
it
if donald trump says we're going to
build a wall don't come out and say
trump's ridiculous this is insane
it's it's you might as well just throw a
banana or a pie it's
it doesn't mean anything it would at
least be entertaining
yeah seriously exactly but but they
don't they don't actually have an
argument other than
let me in yeah this is why i don't think
they actually think trump is all that
bad i really don't i think some people
do
yeah i think they know he's not that bad
and they don't have
half the people who don't like him just
blindly believe
the other people that are just telling
him oh he's bad
oh he's bad oh okay he's bad yeah that's
it
well i mean there's a million and one
videos of like you walk up someone on
the street and say like so why don't you
like the president and they're like uh
oh you you want actual reasons i can't
just give you emotions
yep and this is true for people who ate
hillary too a lot of people very similar
you could do this to either political
faction that's true
but you know i think right now the main
point i'm trying to make is
not that both sides have their dummies
it's that
the high profile pundits of one side are
straight up admitting it now
look they accused brett kavanaugh
did you know what it went crazy do you
know what he was accused of
what like i mean i kind of know this
trying to keep a family friendly man but
that some woman claimed that he'd go to
parties where they would drug women and
line up outside the door
to have to take turns on the drugged
unconscious woman yikes
that is so insane that's messed up yeah
like people were like if anything like
that ever happened it would be one of
the biggest scandals in the history of
like the uni
where did he go to yale i think yeah i
think he went to be like the biggest
scandal in the history of the school
this is ridiculous the story is so
far-fetched yeah and they all it's like
you look at these people
and and you know they're lying and so
they lie about trump and russia gate
we now know like you know what's going
on with russiagate stuff yep like the
the fbi
rogue agents basically setting up trump
staff uh flynn specifically it's crazy
and we'll
we'll see if any indictments come i'll
be surprised but you know maybe the
durham investigation
but then you have that then you have
ukraine gate so we get russiagate
russiagate two
and then we got china gate which is
really really funny there's a br
brief period last week where they tried
claiming that trump was secretly working
for china oh my goodness based off of
one story yeah one story from politico
claiming that trump owed china million
bank of china millions of dollars
and then they had to correct it then
they had to retract and correct it
because they never even reached out for
comment to the bank of china
and it turned out it was a filing error
and that was the basis of their third
scandal so i'll tell you what man
it gets to a point where i've i've never
really you know
to like the way they describe trump as
like
all of these you know pure evil be
embodiment of pure orange evil whatever
i've never
i've never i don't bind to that stuff i
read the news i know they're lying it's
politics
but now they're just they're done it's
like we've exposed their lives so many
times
they finally just it's like i imagine
you've got this democrat standing in
front of you
and they scream donald trump is working
for russia and you go where's your proof
i don't believe it and they keep
screaming it and then finally evidence
comes out trump isn't and they go
well he's pressuring ukraine to dig up
dirt and then you're like
prove it and we've yelled them so many
times you're lying they've finally just
gone
all right we're lying you know wait
wait wait we've we're just going to vote
for him anyway we broke up with the damn
yeah the damn the dem damn the dumb dude
yeah it's like they were wearing a mask
and we were like hammering away at it
and it finally broke
and now they're just like because people
humans are in general aren't distracted
by life they're literally stuck at home
yeah doing nothing but watching the
mainstream media
juggle these like lies they're like oh
fumbling all the lies although well you
got me
yeah they're just lies why is biden
polling higher than trump then
is it true right who's saying it who's
who's polling they're not asking me
yeah that's true yeah no nobody called
me yeah exactly
where are they in poland and one of the
other things too is a lot of trump
supporters claim that they purposefully
lie
trump supporters do yeah they lie oh
like yeah yeah we want biden because
they want biden to win because they want
the turnout to be low
um and if the biden supporters think
they're guaranteed to win they don't
show up
whereas trump supporters are like
they're in vote
definitely they are yeah i mean you look
at the uh the primary
with the republican primary donald trump
you don't need to go vote he's the
nominee he's the incumbent yeah he's
breaking records yeah
because his base wants to vote for him
yeah i mean he feels good trump
supporter they love trump
it's like if you like trump you know if
you're for trump you're like all in 100
like you know it's like it's really
apparent like even people in the chat
right now they're like
trump king trump you know this reminds
me of okay you know that saying i can
run faster scared than you can mad
okay i don't i don't know it you never
heard that so it's like it's
a funny joke where you're about to get
in the fight with somebody and you're
like i can run faster scared than you
can
met i'm terrified you're just mad i get
it like if you're mad i'm gonna run like
ah adrenaline pumping and you're
so it's kind of like that the the people
who are voting against trump
are just angry but they're they're so
the people who want trump feel good when
they go to the polling station and slam
that button for trump it's like michael
moore said
voting for trump would be the biggest fu
in the history of the world
and so people get to feel that when they
go to the polling station be it a
primary or otherwise they're like donald
trump
bam yeah that's true what about the
biden people nobody cares
not really the only thing they have
going for them are the people who want
to go and say
f you trump but i'm willing to bet there
are substantially more people who love
waving trump flags
than people who hate trump i agree i
think definitely
because i think what the left has is a
small a decent it's a large faction
don't get me wrong it's prime in the
millions of like super anti-trump
resistance people sure high profile
ones but most liberals don't care
not paying attention have no idea what's
going on well a lot of liberals out
there probably think biden's a
sleazy old man which no no she pretty
much is some of them
for sure and like they're moving
independent and stuff like that like
there was a gallup poll showing that
people identify as conservative has
ticked up and liberal has ticked down
like i think two points so
i think what we're seeing is there are
going to be regular liberals
who normally go to the polling station
and just hit the d button
they have no idea what's going on true
they don't know they don't care
they don't want to know yeah then you
have
some people who have been lifelong
democrats who i've talked to recently
like friends of mine
who completely agree about joe biden
and this is what what what the the
establishment completely agree that
they don't care okay that you can't vote
for this man right oh okay it's like
what what
what else what what is this what the the
argument you're giving me is to vote for
a dude who's literally
sun setting and can't talk or a guy
who's
who annoys you right okay the options
look man that's what i said it's like i
i need to at least be able to understand
what you're saying you need to speak
coherently
when you're on stage trying to convince
me to vote for you
and and we're gonna see trump versus
biden it's like trump
maybe many things but he can speak right
he's a good speaker he can speak and i
can understand what the words he's
saying sometimes they're a little
far-fetched weird words
biden has it looks like he's trying to
find words to put together
look here's a sentence i made and it's
like yeah it's almost like it makes
sense dude
it's almost like biden is thinking to
himself just keep saying words
and he does cover for him yeah they do
they're like oh man he
said some amazing things he said some
words i mean we
picked in the words and rearranged them
a little a little bit a little bit
let me give you a real argument as to
why you need to support joe biden oh yes
please well it might enlighten me
donald trump is a bad president oh you
got me you sold me that's it
all right yeah sure so would you really
vote for donald trump
what are you a bigot are you racist i
mean i'll answer that yeah i would
you so you're so you admit you're racist
i would vote for trump there it is boom
confirmed adam adam you're racist oh wow
i guess so so so you admit it
no of course not but that's the argument
that's all that's ever said i know it's
so silly no no no no no no no okay i get
it
there used to be arguments the
progressives would say things like
universal health care
yeah you know green new deal jobs
guarantees things like that
hey man i can hear those arguments like
gay marriage all that kind of but
trump's four gay marriage i know that
used to be a thing but now
no longer right now what is joe biden
offering
serious question do you know what joe
biden is offering do you
um i don't i i don't i know
yeah i gotta be honest there's one tweet
that he put out there
i say he in the lightest terms because i
highly doubt
he did any of it but it was basically
about
you know changing our energy
infrastructure
to renewable instead of consumable you
know
do you know what specifically he wanted
to do not really no
i couldn't tell you either man yeah
exactly no no specifics i can tell you
what bernie wanted to do spot
open up the borders bernie wanted a
moratorium on deportations
bernie wanted a path of citizenship yeah
bernie wanted universal health care
bernie wanted to abolish private health
care within the next i think the first
four to six years
bernie wanted tuition-free college
expanded college
i can tell you what bernie wanted and i
can i disagree with those things
and you know what i wish that's what we
actually had
and maybe i took it for granted yeah you
know actually look
ocasio-cortez i can tell you what she
wants
as a politician joe biden
i don't know i don't think he wants
anything i don't think he knows himself
yeah he wants to be president well i
think he wants that
you've seen you've seen the atlantic
article stay alive joe biden yeah yeah
yeah
there's your corporeal essence vote for
joe biden
he's alive okay
and he's not orange thanks for checking
out this clip from the tim cast irl
podcast we do the show
live monday through friday at 8pm if you
want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you